I wanted to do this because
I felt like the only thing
that I could speak very
passionately about is empathy.
You start to realize
that there's more
going on in the world
than you and your dreams.
This class will
help you learn how
to harness the power of
empathy to transform everything
that you do and
everything that you are.
This is one of
those subjects that
just needs many
people to come in here
and talk about it from
their point of view.
Empathy's greatest potential
is equality for all mankind.
We've never seen that.
We don't know what
that looks like.
It's never happened.
CORNEL WEST: What does
it mean to imagine
what it's like to get inside
of the skin of other people?
It's connected to a way
of life, and empathy
is at the center of it.
GLORIA STEINEM:
Empathy allows us
to overcome the labels of race
and gender and caste and class.
WALTER MOSLEY: You can't
have art without empathy.
If you don't understand
the physical and emotional
experience of other creatures,
then your art's gonna be dead.
ROBIN ARZÓN: It feels
good to achieve together.
Even in the most
individualized sport,
empathy will allow
for connection.
ROBERT REFFKIN:
Empathy is most needed
when it comes to
leading and recognizing
that not all people are you.
ROXANE GAY: A lot of us
are very set in our ways.
We think what we think, and
we're not really interested
in outside points of view.
But you don't really ever
grow when you allow yourself
to be constrained like that.
PHARRELL WILLIAMS:
Curiosity and empathy
are the tools that I use when
I'm working in the studio.
Curiosity is the vehicle that
gets you to a place of empathy.
The day that you put a
lid on your curiosity
is the day that you die.
I'm Robin Arzón.
I'm Roxane Gay.
I'm Walter Mosley.
I'm Robert Reffkin.
I'm Gloria Steinem.
I am Cornel West.
I'm Pharrell Williams,
and this is MasterClass.